pour la première fois de son histoire la
centrale nucléaire de zappos ridja se
retrouve totalement déconnectés du
réseau électrique les deux derniers
réacteurs qui étaient reliés à ce réseau
ont dû être débranchés une décision
prise par l'opérateur ukrainien
energoatom en cause selon le groupe des
incendies non loin de la centrale qui
ont déjà provoqué plusieurs déconnexions
de lignes de communication allant
jusqu'à ce réseau électrique les actions
des envahisseurs ont provoqué une
déconnexion totale de la centrale
nucléaire de zappos ridja du réseau
électrique
ukrainiens et russes accusent
mutuellement de frappe autour de la plus
grande centrale d'europe occupé par la
russie qui avait affirme également que
l'armée russe stocks d armes lourdes à
l'intérieur du lieu ce que dément moscou
mais l'inquiétude est chaque jour de
plus en plus grande avec le risque d'un
accident nucléaire ce jeudi matin
emmanuel macron a reçu raphaël grossi le
directeur de l'aiea pour en discuter le
président français a de nouveau appelé à
un envoi rapide sur place d'experts de
l' agence de l'énergie atomique invité
sur france 24
raphaël gros s'il assure cela pourrait
avoir lieu dans quelques jours seulement
je pense que yapi yapi le blocage il y a
eu des doutes il y a eu deux je pense
des objections au niveau politique de
l'un et de l'autre côté je crois qu'on
est très très près de l'acceptation
totale et complète de deux côtes de son
côté l'onu a appelé à une
démilitarisation de la centrale